اكيد عثمان وهذا من خصائص حرب المدن لكن
دعنا نبدا من هذه الصور وما تحدث عنه
الياس كرام الان مراسلنا منذ قليل خاصه في
ما يحدث في جباليه النزله هنا قطاع غزه
كما نشاهد وهذه المناطق الصفراء هي لتوغل
الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى ال 24 ساعه الماضيه
الان التطورات في هذا نبدا من شمال القطاع
وتحديدا مدينه غزه هنا اذا ما توجهنا
اليها كنا نتحدث عن جباليه النزله جباريا
النزله هي تقع هنا في جنوب جباريا
وبالتالي القنابل الدخانيه التي كنا نراها
منذ قليل هي في هذه المنطقه من الممكن ان
تكون هذه القنابل الدخانيه كما ذكر الياس
اما
لتمويه لاشتباكات قريبه للجنود قوات
الاحتلال مع قوات المقاومه في مبان سكنيه
او
لتوغل للتغطيه والتمويه على توغل الاليات
الاسرائيليه كيف يكون ذلك جيش الاحتلال
اعلن انه قام
بالتطويرات
قد تم تطويقها ك ذلك لكن دوما نتحدث عن
توغلات ولا نتحدث عن سيطره كامله هذا بسبب
خصائص هذه الحرب حرب المدن التي يكون فيها
دخول وثم انسحابات بحسب المتطلبات
اي الان ماذا يعني استخدام قنابل الدخان
هنا في جباليا النزله كنا نراها منذ قليل
هذا يعني بان قوات الاحتلال بعد ان قامت
بعمليه التطويق هذه ودخول في مخيم جباليه
ربما ستسعى الى الضغط بهذا العمق بهذا
الاتجاه جنوبا ونشاهد بان هناك نوع من
المطابقه ما بين التصريحات السياسيه
والعمل الميداني بماذا نعني ماذا نعني
بهذا هذا هو الشريط الحدودي الشرقا هناك
محاولات لزياده التوغل في منطقه
الشجاعيه وهذه المناطق هنا بحيث عمل تقوم
قوات الاحتلال بعمل حزام
عازل ما بين السياج والمناطق المكتظه وهي
مناطق تسهل للاليات المدرعه الدخول فيها
والتمركز هذا الامر لم نشاهده فقط في شمال
قطاع غزه هنا اذا ما اتجهنا الى الوسط
قطاع الوسط ايضا كانت هذه المناطق تم
توسيع مناطق التوغل بهذا الاتجاه ولذلك
نسمع في الاخبار عن عمليات استهداف في هذه
المنطقه في القطاع الخ الاوسط لكتائب
المقاومه لقوات متوغلا هنا ام الهدف يبدو
في الاستراتيجيه كما سنشاهدها مره اخرى
بشكل عام نشاهد هذا الشريط تبدو قوات
الاحتلال تحاول تطبيق هذه الاستراتيجيه
ميدانيا على الاقل خلال هذه الايام اذا ما
توجهنا جنوبا قوات الاحتلال كذلك منذ فتره
كانت تحاول التالي التوغل اكثر في اي
محورين رئيسيين في الشمال والجنوب هنا في
الشمال كانت قد دخلت عن
طريق شارع كيس كيسوفيم ثم محور صلاح الدين
والتوغل غربا بالقرب من محور الرشيد حتى
مدينه حمد هنا المطاحن ولكنها لم تطبق
الخناق او لم تطبق على ذلك على خان يونس
وكذلك في الفخاره الان هذه هي ابرز
التطورات بالنسبه لنا كانت عثمان ميدانيا
و